comment vous l'avez vécu c'est
inhabituel parce qu'on ne les invite pas
et que on a toujours les mêmes qui s'en
viennent commenter les les chiffres
nouveaux même si pendant 6 mois ils ont
dit tout et n'importe quoi le contraire
de tout on les invite à nouveau et un
peu comme avec la météo il nous donne le
temps qu'il a fait hier avec une extrême
précision mais rarement le temps qu'il
va faire demain donc non je pense que il
y a dans la philosophie un travail sur
la longue durée il y a des registres et
des vitesses qui sont différentes quand
je travaille à décadences et que
j'embrasse 2000 ans d'histoire
évidemment on a besoin d'un temps long
d'un temps de silence et de méditation
de travail dans son bureau bibliothèque
et cetera et puis après on peut aussi
penser l'actualité on peut penser les
choses un peu chaudes justement en
regard des longues durée c'est-à-dire
que c'est ça me paraît extrêmement
intéressant pour pouvoir voter pour
quelqu'un non pas de se soucier de son
programme parce que là c'est quand même
la foire à la séduction que de se
soucier de son passé c'est très
intéressant le passé des gens et de son
passif peut-être aussi le passé est
souvent impassif donc quand on a vu des
gens qui ont trahi tout dit contraire de
tout qui se sont alliés avec des gens
qui sont devenus leurs amis puis leurs
ennemis puis et cetera bon on voit à peu
près à qui on a affaire quand le général
de Gaulle arrive au pouvoir il a
derrière lui le 18 juin ça aide un peu
d'autres ont ont impassé qui
effectivement un passif souvent de
traître et de donc c'est intéressant ça
permet de savoir c'est pour ça que vous
êtes abstenu alors au premier tour non
c'est pas la vraie raison la vraie
raison c'est qu' il y en a plusieurs il
au moins deux de grosses je dirais la
première c'est qu'en 2005 quand j'ai
fait partie de ceux qui ont voté pour le
référendum contre la formule libérale de
l'Europe et non pas contre l'Europe il y
a eu un un nom massif et en 2008 nous a
dit vous aurez exactement le même texte
et Valérie guscard destin qui dit dans
le point que c'est le même texte
quelques virgules qui ont changé av il
av vous avez absolument raison il juste
pour donner l'impression que c'était un
autre texte quoi on pouveait dire que
formellement c'était un autre texte et
puis les députés et les sénateurs ont
dit ce que le peuple a voulu nous n'en
voulons pas et nous décidons que de
toute façon ce référendum que vous avez
refusé enfin du moins auquel vous avez
répondu par non nous nous y répondons
par oui et vous y aurez droit j'ai
estimé que c'était un coup d'État à sa
manière parce que vous la souveraineté
existe ou le on recour au référendum et
puis on obéit au référendum ou alors on
dit je fais un référendum je souhaite
que ce soit oui si c'est non on mettra à
la poubelle si c'est oui on le garde je
me suis dit à partir de ce moment-là le
devoir du citoyen non pas l'électeur
mais le devoir du citoyen qui est
l'homme politique qui est censé nous
représenter c'est de respecter les les
décisions qui sont prises donc ça c'est
la première raison qui fait que dans la
mesure où il y a une rupture de contrat
social euh je n'y suis pas all restons
sur cette première raison et puis
restant sur cette première raison vous
me développerez dans quelques instants
la deème quand vous dites et on comprend
les cicatrices et les Français les
portent encore sur ce ce référendum et
cette parole non respectée mais
aujourd'hui vous avez eu hier des
candidats qui étaient pour par la sortie
de de l'euro c'est factice selon vous je
vais vous donner la deuxième raison
parce que la la deuxième raison c'est
que en fait tout a été fait pour que le
goulot d'étranglement arrive à ce qui
s'est passé là c'est-à-dire qu'au bout
du compte on nous a dit il y a des
grands candidats des petits candidats
pourquoi les grands sont-ils grands
pourquoi les petits sont-ils petits
c'est étonnant regardez les petits
candidats ce sont tous des gens qui sont
contre la formule libérale de l'Europe
drôle he et tous ceux qui sont des
grands candidats sont tous des gens qui
sont pour la formule de l'Europe vous
vouz dire qu'on a appelé petit candidats
ceux qui sont contre le système non
c'est que lequ vous nous mettez les
médias ah je pas parler de médias pas
encore mais je suppose parce que non non
mais je dis que quand vous avez les les
fameux Grand grands candidats vous en
avez deux qu'on présente comme des
sceptiques Marine Le Pen et Jean-Luc
Mélenchon vous êtes une observatrice
avisé vous aurez bien vu que dans les
derniers temps c'est de nous disaient
que on allait voir qu'on allait négocier
Mélenchon dit moi je vais voir Merkel
quand elle va me voir elle va se calmer
on va refaire un traité là ça va être
autre chose et vous allez voir dans le
genre on garde mais on garde pas tout en
gardant sous-entendu on touche pas à
l'euro on touche pas à l'Europe c'est
bon il pouvait faire partie des grands
Marine Le Pen qui décide de tout des
boutons de guêre elle dit il y aura ceci
ce sera cel-elà et cetera sur la
question de l'Europe c'est la même chose
on négociera après la négociation on
fera un référendum on verra ce que
donnera ce référendum et cetera bon ces
deux-là avaient gagné le droit de faire
partie des grands parce qu'ils avaient
montré des gages au gens qui estiment
que la politique la vraie la seule la
sérieuse c'est de rendre possible alors
si je suis votre raisonnement un
candidat qualifié entre guillemets de
petit mais qu'on aurait dû qualifier
selon vous de grand parce qu'il incarne
une véritable rupture par rapport à
l'euro et à l'Europe ce serait
françoiselino non je dis pas ça je dis
que ce qu'il dit lui alors c'est plus
subtile les médias vous savez bien
c'est-à-dire que ils n'ont pas des gros
sabots c'est quand même beaucoup plus
subtile que ça donc on fabrique la
petitesse du petit candidat on on on
évite une grande visibilité si vous
évitez la visibilité sont pas B B nos
petits candidats ils restent petits
éventuellement on se on se débrouille
pour que des petits candidats obtiennent
500 signatures c'est sidérant ça que des
gens comme Marine Le Pen un temps ne
parvenait pas ou Jean-Luc Mélenchon nous
disait j'ai du mal avec leur surface
politique ils avaient du mal à trouver
500 signatures c'est drôle aselino qui
fait zéro et quelques enfin quasiment en
dessous de zéro il a ses 500 signatures
il y a aucun problème Cheminade il a
aussi ses 500 signatures drôle quand
même que ces gens-là leur signature
parce qu'effectivement drôle ou alors
vivifiant c'est non c'est ironique vous
voyez bien on choisit des comiques on
choisit des guignoles Jean LAL c'est
formidable quand on a un candidat comme
ça il y a pas de problème il est drôle
c'est c'est c'est fantastique c'est la
ruralité il a un
accent la Vierge lui apparaît
régulièrement c'est formidable il est
sympathique moi jeaime beaucoup vousz
pou qui fait son cinéma vous avez to
tout ça est bien est-ce que votre
sympathique n'est pas un peu
condescendant c'est ce que vous nous
reprochez quand vous dites sympathique
on a l'impression qu'il sont là pour
amuser la galerie non mais bien sûr que
qu'on les a choisis pour ça mais bien
sûr que les petits oui on les choisit
pour qu'effectivement on leur facilite
les choses on s'arrange moi je jeai
rencontré Monsieur la salle j'aime
beaucoup il m'avait invité on s'est
rencontré on a déjeuné à l'Assemblée
nationale et il m'expliquait qui le
finançait et comment et c'est assez
intéressant de voir que on se dit ah bon
vous êtes financé par ce monsieur qui
normalement n'a aucun intérêt à vous
financer pourquoi vous êtes financé par
lui et on se voit effectivement on voit
effectivement que des gens ont intérêt
de dire pour la diversité on a des
individus qui sont là et qui vont
montrer que vous avez bien vu que c'est
la démoc mocratie et tout le monde peut
être candidat puisqu'on a même ceux il y
en a un qui va aller sur la Lune il y en
a un autre qui chante en basque il y en
a un autre qui alors c'est quand même
grand la démocratie oui pendant ce
temps-là cela ils permettent finalement
d'amuser la galerie pendant que les
sérieux vous avez vu le premier débat
télévisé on a dit bon les comiques on
les laisse on peut pas avoir on peut pas
avoir 11 personnes on va prendre les
sérieux et avec les sérieux on avait
déjà commencé un tri sélectif mais dans
ce théâtre là parlant des entre
guillemets sérieux vous le dites avec
ironie vous avez vraiment l'impression
que sur l'Europe rien ne changerait que
qu'on donne l'impression parce que là on
présente quand même de candidats que
tout oppose de visions du monde de
visions de la France oui avec un Candel
Macron oui un candidat qui va être élu
un candidat qui ne va pas être élu c'est
fait pour c'est une élection à un tour
l'élection présidentielle et le
président a étaé élu là il y a hier la
preuve il a déjà fait la fête oui c'est
pas parce qu'il a fait la fête que les
Français voilà je vois mal comment un
candidat qui qui a tout le monde pour
lui Macron il a l'Union Rationaliste des
Ath et en même temps le pape il a le
MDEF mais en même temps il a la CGT il a
la droite puis il a la gauche il a Jupé
mais il a aussi qui l'on voudra enfin il
a tout le monde mais donc ça veut dire
qu'il est habile ou qu'il est fabriqué
non il est fabriqué bien sûr qu'il est
fabriqué Jean-Pierre chevetement est un
ami il m'avait dit il y a quelques temps
je peux le dire parce qu'il a redit dans
la presse donc que Benoît Amon avait été
choisi pour perdre c'est intéressant
cette idée choisi pour perdre les gens
ont oublié que il y a eu un bourrage dur
nos partis socialistes ça n'a posé aucun
problème c'était plus important les les
les vestons de de de de Fillon alors oui
oui allons-y pour les vestons de Fillon
mais un bourrage d'ne pourquoi fais-on
un bourrage d'ne au Parti socialiste
c'est quand même étonnant ça non non il
y a eu un bourrage d' on a expliqué en
24 heures qu'on avait mal compté qu'il a
fallu recomter et c mon œil quand on
bourre les urnes c'est parce qu'on veut
pousser un candidat pourquoi est-ce
qu'on pousse un candidat en évitant en
faisant de telle sorte que il puisse
descendre tellement bas que ça ouvre la
route à Macron dont on découvre qui nous
écoute un peu ce soir il se disent oh là
là Michel enfry il est un peu
complottiste je vous donne des faits je
je vous donne des faits je vous dis
aujourd'hui François Hollande nous a dit
que il fallait voter Macron il l'a dit
il y a 3 mois déjà ou 2 mois parce que
pour les gens qui suivent un peu nes pas
tombé de votre chaise non non non mais
pas du tout mais il est allé au Liban
notre ami Macron quand vous allez au
Liban et que vous êtes reçu par
l'ambassadeur ça veut dire que le kedoré
a donné son autorisation donc le chef de
l'État donne son accord Marine Le Pen
est allé aussi reçu par le président pas
par les même c'est pas exactement la
même chose dis voilà oui non mais le
président du Liban il est souverain et
autonome il reçoit qu'il veut en
revanche quand vous êtes reçu par
l'ambassadeur du Liban vous êtes reçu
par la France on dit que c'est le
candidat du système le candidat de la
République candidat du président oui oui
c'est ça c'était le candidat du
président donc tout a été fait pour
qu'il soit élu et il va être élu mais
au-delà peut-être des candidats et c'est
ce que vous pointez souvent Michel
enonfre c'est peut-être ce qui est plus
inquiétant au-delà de du nom d'un tel ou
d'une tel c'est que selon vous on a
renoncé à notre souveraineté
c'est-à-dire que vous dites oui
directement qu'prend nos ordres à
Bruxelles ça veut dire quoi que que
demain le 8 mai euh on va passer un cô
de fil à à qui à à Madame Merkel ah
c'est pas nous qui allons passer des
coups de fil on va nous passer des coups
de fil comme on sonne un domestique en
disant monsieur le Président d'ailleurs
vous avez vu he la aujourd'hui c'est
extraordinaire la bourse c'est
formidable tous les marchés sont
rassurés moi j'ai lu la presse ce matin
en Allemagne on souffle aux États-Unis
on voit que les marchés sont très
heureux très content on a bien voté les
marchés sont sont sont tranquilles sont
heureux sont contents ben voilà tout est
fait pour ça donc oui effectivement le
chef de l'État qui nous donne
l'impression qu'il va choisir ne
choisira rien parce que le où il sera
élu on lui fera savoir ce qu'il faut
faire parce qu'il y a une feuille de
route la feuille de route elle est à BR
qu'est-ce que vous proposez est-ce qu'il
faut faire exploser quoi les règles du
jeu c'est un état je propose ça moi
propose mastrichien c'est ça mastrichen
ou il faut le casser et qu'est-ce qu'il
faut faire une révolution parce
qu'Emmanuel Macron vous avez lu son
livre ou vu le titre ah oui ça c'est
pour rire révolution chez Macron
laissez-moi rire qu c'est quoi une vraie
révolution alors elle doit se faire dans
dans la rue avec C alors soit on est
dans la logique de de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
c'est la révolution jacobine couple les
têtes c'est c'est Robespierre moi c'est
mon c'est mon ennemi Robespierre je
pense que on ne doit pas pouvoir faire
couler couler le sang et les guillotines
sont à sont à refuser moi mon modèle
c'est plutôt la Commune de Paris la
Commune de Paris met le feu à la
guillotine dans ce que je propose ici
c'est effectivement une révolution si on
veut mais je veux pas galvoder le mot je
dis juste qu'on doit sans sans faire
couler le sang évidemment sans couper
des têtes même symboliquement même
réellement dire réorganisant les choses
autrement c'est-à-dire que on a le vieux
schéma la Cité de Dieu la cité des
hommes chez Saint-Augustin on nous dit
dans le ciel il y a un dieu donc sur
terre il faut qu'il son équivalent et
c'est la monarchie pendant des siècles
la Révolution française dit on arrête
avec la monarchie il y a deux courants
dans la Révolution française un premier
qui est jacobin et qui nous dit on
arrête sans arrêter tout en arrêtant
c'est-à-dire que Robespierre restaure le
culte de lettre suprême le temple de la
raison en disant il faut de la mystique
pour faire de la politique la mystique
c'est moi en gros c'est moi le chef j'ai
avec moi le clerger et puis donc ça veut
dire que on a une descente comme ça on a
ça sort du ça descend du haut comme ça
et c'est ce qu'on appelle la hiérarchie
éthymologiquement le pouvoir du sacré et
ça ça descend jusqu'au sujet jusqu'au
manaintenant et les manant ils obéissent
le dit il faut faire ça pas faire ça sur
le marché vous n'avez pas le droit
d'exposer un lapin parce que les
directives de Bruxelles vous expliquent
que si vous n'avez pas une chambre
froide qui a été achetée à tel endroit
avec les normes ceci et ce vous pouvez
pas donc voilà c'est le système que vous
vouzcarte en VO l'invers je dis on part
de la base et cette révolution que je
propose si vous voulez vraiment qu'on
utilise le mot mais moi je l'utilise non
c'est la pensée provinciale plutô que ça
sppelle oui si vous voulez si on peut la
résumer d'ailleurs ça consiste en quoi
c'est euh c'estêtes vous y êtes toujours
vous c'est formidable les provinces et
la province pas dit le contraire je pas
dit que vous l'aviez dit je dis juste
que quand on est quand on on veut faire
de la politique à partir de la base on
dit il y a des intelligences collectives
il y a des gens qui savent des paysans
des agriculteurs des instituteurs des
médecins des gens de terrain des gens
qui sont là qui savent comment ça marche
une vigne comment ça marche un village
comment ça fonctionne et cetera et
cetera donnons redonnons le pouvoir aux
communes avec des gens qui sont
susceptibles de faire de telle sorte que
le citoyen fasse le pouvoir c'est le
principe de l'autogestion et puis après
ça grimpe c'està dire ça descend pas du
ciel ça grimpe jusqu'à un état on va pas
rentrer dans le détail mais on peut
constituer un état qui soit libertaire
parce qu'il serait la garantie des
libertés plutôt que l'État théocratique
qui décide que il est autoritaire et le
chef décidera pour tout le monde nous
attendons des solutions d'un homme
providentiel c'est pour c'est pourquoi
d'ailleurs ils nous séduisent avec moi
il y aura il y aura plus de neige vous
préférez la fameuse descence
ordinaire oui mais j'aime les gens qui
sont qui sont au contact vous dire très
sincèement la vérité je reçois de
nombreux invités vous le dites vous avec
talent cette forme de d'État finalement
nouveau que vous voulez mais d'autres
l'ont dit il n'y arrivent pas pourquoi
est-ce qu'on narrive pas
justement d'autres personnalités qui ont
venu de la société civile qui ont voulu
incarner cela cet état là qui serait
moins centralisé et cetera il oh si vous
voulez que je cite des noms il y a
Alexandre Jardin il y en a d'autres
pourquoi est-ce qu'on y écoutez sérieux
mais pourquoi votre votre j'allais
direard ilid tion marcherait plus que
celle des autres qui basé sur la même
idée je dis pas ça je dis qu'Alexandre
jardin il avait une excellente idée il a
dit à un moment donné il va falloir que
une espèce de consultation citoyenne
permettre de faire monter de faire
émerger un nom j'ai trouvé ça
extrêmement intéressant quel est la
méthode on FR et comment ça s'est passé
avec jardin un jour il a dit au fait le
nom qui émerge c'est le mien et c'est
moi qui serai le candidat de cette
société et d'un seul coup les gens ils
ont découvert à la radio à la télévision
qu'Alexandre jardin c'était autoproclamé
candidat de la société civile il a pas
obtenu ses signatures c'était pitoyable
c'est idé était
bonne d'ailleurs quelquesunes de ces
idées sont Bones par gardons l'idée pour
vous dit à jacobin quelquesunes de ces
idées sont Bones parce sont bonnes parce
que c'est les miennes ce sont les
miennes et que il connait mon travail et
que il s'en sert assez régulièrement non
non mais c'est très bien bon entendeur
oui il est venu à l'université populaire
il connait mon travail et puis vous
savez quand bonne chose quand on
s'inspire des idées des autres c'est
qu'elles sont bonnes ce qui est mieux
c'est de les citer parce que là au moins
on est capable de dire qu'on peut
travaill en synergie que par
exempleuniversité populaire c'est très
exactement une proposition concrète et
qui rentrait tout à fait dans les
projets ou les prrammes d'Alexandre
Jardin mais c'est pas important
Alexandre Jardin je pense que ce qui
était important c'était cette idée qui a
été dévoyée hélas c'est cette bonne idée
à l'origine d'Alexandre Jardin elle a
été dévoyé par quelqu'un dont on a
découvert qu'il était dans une logique
jacobine il a dit on a besoin d'un chef
et le chef ce sera moi il est dans cette
logique là et si vous on devait vous
classer je sais que c'est très difficile
que vous n'aimez pas ça mais est-ce
qu'on pourrait dire une gauche
antibérale et profondément libertaire ah
ben c'est ça si vous voulez des
étiquettes allons-y oui oui oui
absolument gauche antilibérale c'est ma
cohérence depuis le début donc certains
pointent en disant oui mais une fois il
y a eu celui-ci puis une fois il y a eu
celui-là et cetera je dis mais oui on
peut effectivement imaginer qu'il y a
des contradictions dans cette dans cette
aventure mais je vous rappelle que ce
qui lia ces individusl c'est
effectivement une gauche antilibérale et
précisément une gauche libertaire et et
et je dis qui est le personnage qui
m'inspire c'est proudon et c'est un
socialisme libertaire justement qui qui
démarre des des des communes des
communautés de de l'autogestion du
talent des gens mais quand vous dénoncez
critiquer l'Europe vous savez ce qu'on
va vous dire on va vous accuser de tous
les mot MS max tout oui oui bon ça j'ai
un peu l'habitude le problème c'est pas
ce qu'on dit de moi ou ce qu'on pense de
moi c'est que des gens puissent entendre
un discours alternatif et que les gens
puissent se faire directement un avis
c'était pour arriver à cela que je
voulais que je vous disais ça on ne veut
pas entendre un discours alternatif sur
l'Europe aujourd'hui parce qu'on a eu
quand même l'impression nous pendant ce
débat qu'il y a eu quand même pas mal de
candidats souverainistes qui voulit la
sortie de l'EUR qui voulait faire la
peau à l'Europe oui mais lesquels des
gens qu'on a pas cétait de nouveau
François SL on va croire que je soutiens
son score voilà voilà mais pourtant ces
idées ne sont pas audibles c'est c'est
la question de il beaucoup cité de
textes et d'articles il av pas de tort
ça ça simplement fait ça a généré des
des colibé le lendemain on s'est moqué
de lui en disant là il y avait des
comices alors que lui montrait qu'il
fallait tenir tenir compte de ces règles
du jeu pour les contourner absolument il
disait mais en fonction de cet article
vous ne pourrez pas faire ce que vous
annoncez on peut pas entendre ce
propos-là qui est un propos juste et un
propos vrai dis mais simplement si vous
restez dans cette règle du jeu vous ne
pourrez pas et et c'est dit ça n'est pas
entendu ça n'est pas compris et on dilue
tout ça parce qu'on dit bon c'est aussi
un personnage qui fait partie de ceux
qui estiment qu'on doit pouvoir aller
sur la lune et donc on se dit B
évidemment si si c'est l'idée de
quelqu'un qui pense qu'il faut se
dépêcher pour partir sur la lune bah
voilà quoi c'est c'est c'est l'idée de
quelqu'un de lunaire pour rester euh le
divorce Paris province c'est une rupture
permanente comment la soigner
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il faut mettre
plus de de justice tout simplement de
bon sens
mais les les Girondins disaient très
précisément il y avait 83 départements à
l'époque hein les Girondins disaient
Paris doit peser 1 83e de la
représentation nationale bah voilà ça me
paraît normal que Paris ne pèse pas 95 %
pendant que com pèse Paris aujourd'hui
non je dis 95 une majorité on dira et et
que tout se passe là moi j'habite en
Normandie si on doit prendre un un train
si on quand il y en a si on doit prendre
un avion si on doit et cetera enfin tout
passe par Paris si on veut voir son
éditeur si on veut venir s'exprimer sur
les sur les chaînes nationales mais
effectivement il y a pas de
décentralisation il faut passer par
Paris tout est à Paris et effectivement
c'est une vraie révolution d'imaginer
que on pourrait redonner aux provinces
des pouvoirs et notamment de de redonner
du pouvoir ça serait donc celle-là selon
vous la vraie révolution je reviens à
l'autre révolution que vous avez
critiqué tout à l'heure parce que encore
une question en tête malgré Michel hfry
il n'était pas connu il y a quelques
mois quelques années en tous les cas
Emmanuel Macron sans parti sans soutien
il en a eu beaucoup après vous les
connaissez on peut on peut les citer
est-ce que ce n'est pas quand même un
changement en douceur même si le mot
révolution est galvudé malgré tout on
découvrira un jour que la Bible de ces
gens-là c'est horwell c'est-à-dire que
vous avez des cabinets de consultation
qui ont fabriqué un programme qui n'est
pas un programme voilà un homme qui nous
dit il y a pas besoin d'avoir un
programme les Français l'auraient avalé
tout cru comme ça évidemment puisque
c'est c'est tous les jours c'est tous
les jours qu'on vous fait savoir que
finalement il y a les mauvais d'un côté
il y a les bons de l'autre que les
mauvais ils sont parfois ridicules
parfois et cetera les comics s'en
donnent à cœur joie et puis à un moment
donné où vous finissez par dire bah
finalement il reste plus que celui-là
regardez à quoi ça ressemble aujourd'hui
toute la palinodie de gens qui disent
non on va pas voter pour Macron on va
voter contre Marine Le Pen ben en gros
ils sont bien obligés de voter pour
celui qui qui a été choisi par par ces
cabinets de consultation où on se dit
voilà il y a des segments il va falloir
draguer ceuxl alors là jour on dit il y
a pas de culture il a pas de culture
française une autre fois on va en
Algérie et on va parler du génocide une
autre fois on va flatter la croupe du
cheval de de Jean contrection des
responsables politiques c'est pas
nouveau non non mais à chaque fois vous
avez
emmagasiné un secteur un segment de la
société et quand vous avez dit du bien
de Jeanne d'c quand vous avez dit du
bien du général de Gaulle quand vous
avez dit du bien de François mitteran
quand vous avez dit du bien des des du
FLN par exemple en Algérie quand vous
avez dit qu'il y avait pas de culture
française et que vous avez séduit tous
les incultes ça fait du monde et bien il
y a un moment donné où chacun n'entend
que ce qui lui a été dit personnellement
il dit mais ça ça me va et ce personnage
on va laisser de côté le reste
finalement je vais voter pour lui voilà
pourquoi on a des gens comme Robert U
qui soutiennent cet individu qui est
aussi soutenu par sera pas au
gouvernement oui oui oui non mais on
cite souvent le l'arc de Robert à
Madelin et ben oui alors comment Madelin
donc c'est quand même c'est quand même
un coup de force que de réussir un
programme de com c'est ce qui fait qu'un
jour comme comme par hasard vous allez
acheter cette instrument ce téléphone
cette voiture je ne sais quoi un jour
tout est fait dans la logique
publicitaire pour que le jour où vous
ayez besoin d'une lécive vous achetiez
la lécive Macron en tous les cas votre
Révol